quel mot à dire a dit m malgré les
condamnations fille renée les geeks et
nous nous y sommes fermement contre 9,6
milliards vers nous
donc comme des mouches mots clés ou
idéologie ou léo aveugle et sourd cela
me fait que m
elle est cool et le bento et l'ourdou
dit merci donc à l'eau donc je commence
déjà les ans le compteur à démarrer
ils m'ont dit aussi que je vais être le
premier à parler et moi qui a rêvé
toujours de parler le dernier rien que
pour avoir le dernier mot
mais j'ai jamais eu le dernier mot et je
crois que je n'aurais jamais le dernier
haut c'est une illusion
donc que faire
je pense que le dernier mot sera donné
par le temps ou peut-être par le peuple
ou que 16 l'essentiel c'est de parler je
pense se dire des mots des mots
c'était très important de parler aux
gens c'est toujours un moment magique ce
moment ici et maintenant vous dans la
salle et moi ici en s'adressant à vous
ce sens et vous sentez ce moment magique
de la vie c'est ça fait partie de la vie
ces moments de rencontre des choses et
de communication
c'est toujours les mots les mots qui
blessent les mots qui soigne et les mots
aussi qui nous transporte qui nous
transforme le sujet et les limites
pousser les limites mais a priori penser
que si on dit par exemple la liberté en
trace des limites à lille à la liberté
ce n'est plus la liberté la liberté sont
mouvants c'est comme la vie avance
toujours
si quelqu'un vient vous dire il ya des
limites à la liberté donc voilà la
limite ce n'est plus la liberté et les
limites aussi dans notre vie si on les
définit son nous dit vous avez des
limites
là vous avez des problèmes vous ce n'est
plus des problèmes parce qu'on les
connaît déjà
ça nous étonne pas on peut les affronter
donc c'est ça
vous avez peut-être lu un peu sur le
prospectus ce que faisait ce que j'ai
modestement fait mais il ya une
indication que qui n'existe pas dans le
prospectus
bon je suis comédien metteur en scène et
du réseau des centres d'art dramatique
et tout mais eux ils n'en parlent ils
ont ils ont ils ont fait une omission
c'est à dire qu'ils ont oublié de dire
que j'étais timide
c'était très timide oui et je me suis
confronté à moi même je me suis soigné
comme on dit commencé par le théâtre par
l'art par me mettre dans des situations
de confrontation comme ça mais parce que
j'ai su mais limités j'ai su que s'il
reste timide je vais rater beaucoup
d'occasions je vais rater
peut-être une bonne partie de ma vie
qu'est ce que la vie c'est des occasions
c'est des expériences et tout ça donc le
théâtre j'ai commencé à faire le théâtre
des mots jeune âge mon journal c'est à
dire que mon adolescence avec des amis
au lycée j'ai fait aussi de la
photographie au lycée ah oui on faisait
ça dans le lycée c'était dans les années
soixante dix vous allez finir par
calculé mon âge
vous êtes donc voilà et puis j'ai fait
des études en arts dramatiques à tunis
et puis le cinéma le cinéma qui nous
transforme qui nous fait rêver qui nous
fait avancer dans la vie j'aime beaucoup
le cinéma vous était un grand fervent de
tintin et son chien milou cost et
enfants ça me transformer ses aventures
ses confrontations alors et j'aime bien
j'aime bien signalé à notre ami joe 2
baltes about what american movie about
cow boys - waziers connections enfants
on ne transmettait des films des films
qui parle des indiens et nous surtout
dans des moments de l'aïd
on allait au cinéma c'était des moments
magiques aussi et quand on voit que
l'armée américaine que les indiens on se
met à applaudir et soutenir l'armée
américaine et les cowboys kitty les
indiens et ça c'est triste maintenant
quand je repense à ça mais cela
n'empêche que le cinéma nous a donné
beaucoup de choses nous a fait voyager
alors qu'est ce que le temps est pressé
je vais vous parler comment on peut
aussi à travers plusieurs éléments de la
vie dépasser soi-même dépasser ses
limites et alors il ya plusieurs
éléments mais puisque le temps et les
limiter j'ai préparé des feuilles sfl
assez pour faire un tirage au sort alors
4 il ya quatre à quatre possibilités à
il ya l'amour il ya le voyage il ya
l'amitié
et puis il y a aussi le challenge le
défi
donc je vais faire semblant de tourner
tout autour et je vais tirer de dire
cela celle-là non celle là c'est là que
je ne sais pas de quoi je vais vous
parler les voyages je suis désolé pour
ceux qui attendaient qu'on va parler de
l'amour mais je vais parler de l'amour
pendant les voyages c'est intéressant
non mais j'ai pas tricher n'osais pas
tricher que ce qu'indique d'être ici
patrick amour à ses voyages
je pense que le jeu je pense que le jeu
que le jeu est truqué
je suis désolé de façon on est habitué à
truquer les choses vite
en tunisie on est toujours on a toujours
truquer les élections entre et où donc
ça va pas vous faire mal je sais on est
habitué on est vaccinés contre ça mais
les voyages c'est important les voyages
quand on voyage c'est que on voyage on
nous mêmes aussi puisque j'aime le
cinéma j'ai pris l'avion si vous allez à
bagdad à bagdad pour apprendre parce que
j'ai j'ai omis de vous dire que je suis
dans un je suis d'origine d'un village à
bizerte à mesure des semaines peut-être
un modeste village et d'une modeste
famille ici et là je suis parti parce
qu'il n'y avait pas moyen de faire du
cinéma en tunisie
c'était très facile à cette époque parce
qu'il y avait ni école de cinéma il y
avait l'école d'architecturé ne vous
inquiétez pas et puis c'est un trip si
c'était pas c'était très facile
ce qui veut faire des cinémas des gaz
beau voir ailleurs donc on n'avait pas
les moyens donc j'y suis allé à bagdad
et dès que je suis arrivé à bagdad et a
eu la guerre c'était en 88 e la guerre
entre l'irak et l'iran
j'ai pas rater mon voyage j'ai ainsi
j'ai passé deux mois la guerre et j'ai
travaillé comme ouvrier à l'aéroport en
construction sur l'aéroport de cette
dame assise et je me suis confronté avec
moi même avec ma timidité
j'ai travaillé avec des sedanais avec
des des pakistanais et puis je me suis
confronté avec la peur la guerre ne me
fait plus peur c'était un truc quotidien
et même pendant le soir compte y aller
les fusées compte y aller l'esam 6 les
5,5 dont le ciel les avions
c'était très beau avoir cédé comme
disney m'a c'était génial le soir avec
mes copains on est là dans le jardin on
se cassait pas ont regardé
et puis là avec le théâtre en faisant
des spectacles en jouant des personnages
c'était aussi c'était aussi des voyages
je voyage avec ses personnages je voyage
aussi en faisant en faisant des
spectacles on a fait damas on a fait
l'egypte on a fait beaucoup de beaucoup
de pays mais mais je pense je vais vous
dire un truc mais ne le répétez pas
après c'est que les pays lawzi dit ou
presque tous les pays que j'ai visitée
après mon départ il a eu la guerre donc
je demande à mes amis mes amis étrangers
ne m'invitez pas chez vous je vous en
prie je vous avertis si vous allez
m'éviter chez vous alors la garde à vue
risque d'avoir soit la guerre soit des
séismes soit des inondations donc
laissez moi là où je suis et ça se passe
bien
donc voilà joué aussi au cinéma pour moi
c'était des moments très forts des
moments magiques jouer aussi à la télé
soit les télé tunisienne ou bien avec
des films étrangers interpréter des
personnages comme ça je me souviens d'un
personnage qui est le césar dans un film
vécu la bbc un césar j'étais un césar
donc eu donc ça te transforme tous les
personnages que tu jour est en toi tu
leur donnes de toi même et il récupère
d'avis aussi et donc
donc tout ça c c'est à la fois un voyage
on nous mêmes et un voyage dans le temps
et dans l'espace
ce qui est très important je pense c'est
de voyager voyager dans l'espace dans le
temps mais surtout voyagé en soi même
sur ces refus six ans dans notre vie en
faisant le tous les diagnostics des
limites de nous mêmes
les affronter c'est ça aussi un voyage
les connaître d identifier si on veut
évoluer ses des expériences faire
toujours des expériences affronter le
prendre nous a mais prendre des sentiers
battus aller dans des directions
s'il n'est pas scellé pas qu'ils font
qui font le chemin pas autre chose
allez toujours envers vous même et là je
suis content de m'adresser un public
potentiel qui fait dans l'art dans
l'architecturé moi aussi j'ai rêvé de
faire de la lecture mais j'avais été nul
en mathématiques
vous devez donc j'ai pas pu j'ai pas pu
accéder aussi à ça mais cela n'empêche
que il est toujours important pour tout
artiste d'essayer de ne pas aller dans
les sentiers battus d'avancé d'aller
toujours chercher soi-même dans d'autres
semaine parce que l'esma là où tout le
monde y va c'est pas dire que ce sont
des chemins qu'humaine écoutez je veux
vous dire
finalement je pense que que je vous ai
pas vraiment convaincu mais je vais je
vais vous donner une bonne adresse
si vous voulez la notte vous pouvez la
noter un pur si vous voulez vous changer
si vous voulez dépasser vos limites
allez dans cette adresse l'adresse est
la suivante le miroir regarder dans un
miroir
ce que vous allez voir évidemment c'est
vous même c'est celui là qui va vous
changer c'est pas moi se désole merci